a proposal to make public sector
websites more accessible and
user-friendly was assessed today by EU
ministers responsible for
Telecommunications
in the council today
the member states unanimously were in
favor of giving new impetus to our work
in this area we think it's important for
the purposes of civilization
it's important though
we complete much of the work over the
next few weeks and that we can bring it
to a happy conclusion
having the same rules in all EU
countries would help website developers
offer their products and services across
the 28 member states without extra costs
for having to comply with different
National rules
new rules regarding the EU
telecommunications Market are also part
of the agenda
roaming charges for travelers in the EU
were discussed as well as the principles
of net neutrality which concerns the
management of internet traffic by
internet service providers
a document on internet governance was
approved based on an inclusive model
founded on human rights and Democratic
Values
finally ministers have acknowledged the
importance of the 2020 strategy and the
way telecommunications can further
contribute to growth and competitiveness